KATE: Please
welcome to the stage
today our guest Barry Meier.
BARRY MEIER: Thanks.
Thanks, Kate.
Thanks to everyone at
Google for having me here.
And thanks to all
of you for coming.
I've been a journalist
at the New York Times
for over 25 years.
And people often ask me, why
did you become a journalist?
And the truth is, I did it after
I failed at a couple of things.
And one of the things I
really failed spectacularly at
was being a fiction writer.
When I was in my
early 20s, I really
wanted to be a suspense
writer, someone that
wrote mystery and crime novels.
Because I had grown up
loving those kinds of books.
I read people like Dashiell
Hammett, and Raymond Chandler,
and James M. Cain,
and John Le Carre.
And I loved those stories,
both for their excitement
and the kind of ambiguity of
the morality of the stories.
It was often very difficult to
tell who the good guys were,
who the bad guys were.
And I thought, hey,
this can't be too hard.
I should be able to do this.
So I spent a year
in my early 20s
in what was then a
very cheap apartment
in Little Italy,
something I know
that doesn't exist anymore.
And I spent every
day going, sitting
at a table with then
the preferred writing
implement of its time,
a manual typewriter,
and click clacking away
for five or six hours
and writing what I thought
was a really great novel.
And it was set-- the
climatic scene of this novel,
was set on what was the
old West Side Highway.
I don't know if any of
you have ever seen it
when it was in existence,
but along what was now
West Street was an
elevated highway,
where you could drive
from Lower Manhattan
all the way up to the
Henry Hudson Parkway.
And you'd pass all
the piers and ships
that used to line the
West Side of Manhattan.
And in the 1970s, I believe,
during the financial crisis
here in New York,
they decided not
to paint the underside
of the West Side Highway.
And one day, sections
of it collapsed.
So basically it was not
useful for cars anymore,
but it became, really, this
incredible urban walkway,
where you could walk from
Lower Manhattan along the now
decrepit West Side Highway
up to Central Park,
or ride your bicycle along
the old West Side Highway.
And it was really
a fantastic place.
So I had this scene, where
the climax of my book
was taking place, set on
the West Side Highway.
And basically I pictured
it like a high noon
scene out of a
Western novel, where
the good guy was approaching
from one end of the highway
and the bad guy was
approaching from the other end
of the highway and there was
this shootout that took place.
And I figured, man,
this is just fantastic.
People are going to
eat this novel up.
Sadly, that didn't turn
out to be the case.
I mean, it was roundly
rejected by every publisher
who I brought it to.
And it is now in the bottom
of a closet somewhere
in my apartment.
If any of you are
interested or know people
in the publishing industry
who might like to buy it,
you can come see me afterwards.
So fast forward 25, 30 years.
I'm at the New York Times.
Prior to the Times, I had worked
both at the Wall Street Journal
and at New York Newsday,
another newspaper
here in New York City.
And I'd spent a large
majority of my career
as an investigative reporter.
And one of the things that I
had specialized in investigating
were problems with drugs,
problems with medical devices,
or surgical procedures.
I was the first reporter
that wrote extensively
about the drug OxyContin.
This is about 15 years
ago when it was first
appearing as here hillbilly
heroin in Appalachia
and other places.
And then I wrote a book
called "Pain Killer," which
traced the story of this drug
and prescription drug abuse
and this really fascinating
family, the Sackler
family, that ran the company
that produced OxyContin.
And one of the things that
is both one of the benefits
and the downsides of being
an investigative reporter
is that your bosses give you
a lot of leeway to pursue
subjects of interest to you.
And they are really happy
if those stories work out.
If you win awards, you get
a lot of slaps on the backs,
occasionally a raise.
And you are then allowed to
continue on and pursue whatever
story you want to pursue.
The big downside is that there
are these lull periods, where
you can't find a story.
And you begin to
worry that, oh my god,
they're going to
realize that I've been
a fraud for the last 20 years.
The secret is going to be out
that I've been scamming them.
I've been coming up with these
stories and it's all been luck,
and I've been living
by my wits and now it's
all going to come
to a crashing end.
And it was really the
state that I was in 2007.
I had just won a couple
of notable awards
for doing a series of stories
about a defective heart device
and got the typical
pats on the back.
And then I was
thinking, I'm really
sick of doing medical stuff.
Let me see if I can find
something else to do.
So month after month
after month went by.
I was looking for stories.
I was trying to find
things and I was really
starting to get desperate.
And I also saw the looks
in my editors' eyes,
or thought I saw the looks in
my editors' eyes looking at me
and saying "what's Barry doing?
Why isn't he doing anything?
Do we need to call him in
and have a talk with him?"
So I was walking around
the newsroom one day,
and I was so desperate
to find something
that I picked up a copy of
the Financial Times, which
is an English newspaper.
It covers business.
I never read it.
I mean, I'd be more likely
to pick up a copy of the Post
or the Daily News than
the Financial Times.
And what was so pathetic about
this was the fact that it
wasn't even today's-- that
day's Financial Times.
It was probably six months old.
But that was a kind of
state that I was in.
And as I'm thumbing
through this newspaper,
I see a story that
catches my attention.
And the story basically
reports that a former FBI agent
turned private investigator has
disappeared in Iran while he
was investigating a case
involving smuggled counterfeit
cigarettes.
And I thought, hm, this
sounds kind of cool.
I know something about
the tobacco industry.
I had covered all the litigation
between the state attorney
generals and the
tobacco companies
back in the late
1990s and early 2000s,
when states were suing
tobacco companies.
And I knew people
that were involved,
private detectives that worked
on counterfeit cigarette cases.
And then I continued
reading the story further,
and there was this other
line in the story that
talked about how this gentleman
by the name of Robert Levinson
had disappeared
while he was meeting
in Iran with a fugitive American
murderer, a black American who
had fled to Iran in
1980 during the height
of the Iranian Revolution
after he had assassinated
a former aide to
the Shah of Iran
outside that person's
home in Washington DC.
This person's name
was Dawud Salahuddin.
That's the name that he
adopted after fleeing to Iran.
And I thought to myself, wow.
This sounds incredibly cool.
This is my ticket.
This is a life saver for me.
This is in 2007,
the fall of 2007,
and it's already about six
months after this episode
has taken place.
OK, I'm going to
go to my editors.
I'm going to lay
claim to the story.
And the bonus of the
story is that the Times
is going to pay for me to travel
to all kinds of cool places.
I'll get to go to Dubai.
I really want to see
those islands that
look like palm trees.
I'll get to go to Iran.
I mean, how many people
get to go to Iran
and have their
employer pay for it?
And I'm thinking, not only
do I have a good story here,
I have the best of both
worlds, because the Times is
going to go pay for me to
see all these exotic places.
So I make this pitch.
My editors, they're
a little skeptical
but they seem
vaguely interested.
And I figured I'm saved.
I've got it going.
I'm good.
OK, full speed ahead.
So I start calling these
private investigators
that I know who work in the
area of smuggle cigarettes.
And I tell them this story
and I get the same thing back
from them, which is basically,
this sounds totally crazy.
There is no way under the
sun that we would ever
send a former FBI agent,
basically a big fat white guy
with a Jewish last name, to
Iran to investigate a case.
If we were going to
investigate a case in Iran,
we would send in
a local, someone
who looked Iranian, who was
Iranian, who spoke Farsi,
who could blend in to Iran.
I mean, there's just no way.
I mean, all you would be
doing is inviting trouble
by sending in a former FBI agent
to investigate a case in Iran.
And I have to say, I came away
from those conversations a bit
depressed.
I figured, oh my god.
Now I've really dug a
deep hole for myself.
I've told them about this story.
I've made it sound
really exciting to them,
and now I've got to go and
look like a dope and say,
you know what?
I was wrong.
And I figured this is it.
This is the end of my career.
So I guess I got
depressed and moped around
for another week or two.
And then I get this phone call.
And the phone call
was from a guy
that I know, another journalist
who worked for the Times
for a period of time, who I was
friendly with, who says to me,
I understand you're poking
around the Levinson story.
I have no idea how he knew
about that, but he says to me,
there's nothing going on there.
I wouldn't really pay
any attention to it.
But if you're
interested in it, I
know someone who knows
something about Levinson who
might be willing to help you.
He's a former television
producer, a retired television
producer by the name
of Ira Silverman.
So maybe, if you want, I can
let him know you're calling
and you can call him.
So I figure, OK, at this point
I've got nothing to lose.
So I call Ira Silverman.
We start chatting,
and he's acting
very hush hush, conspiratorial.
There's something
he wants to tell me,
but it's so secret
and so sensitive I've
gotta double promise
on the life of everyone
I've known in this
life and possibly
every previous life
I've lived before he
will share the secret with me.
And so I do that,
and he tells me
that Bob Levinson
works for the CIA.
And he went to Iran on
a mission for the CIA.
And I'm thinking to
myself, either this guy
is really crazy, or
this guy is telling me
something that's amazing.
And so I talked to
Ira a little bit more.
And Ira tells me that
the family is frantic.
They haven't heard anything
about Bob or his fate
ever since he's disappeared.
The FBI doesn't seem
to be investigating
his disappearance, and
the CIA has said nothing
to the family about
what's happened to Bob.
And I say, OK.
And he says to me, well,
I'm coming to New York.
And I'm coming to New York with
a lawyer for the family, a guy
by the name of Dave McGee.
And we'd be very eager
to meet with you.
So I said sure.
This is great.
And so I meet with them
around Thanksgiving of 2007.
And they show me a
contract that Bob has.
It actually shows
that Bob Levinson
was at a certain point,
a consultant for the CIA.
And I don't know.
Is there any one
here that-- you guys
do are this spooky stuff--
who has worked for the CIA
or doesn't want to admit
to people around you
that they work for the CIA?
No one's raise their hand.
OK.
So as you may know, there
are two parts to the CIA.
There's the spy side, the
people who go out and work
abroad doing spying.
And that's called the Division
of Clandestine Operations.
Or now it's called the National
Secrecy something or other.
And then there's
the analytical side,
which is called the
Directorate of Intelligence.
And the analytical
side basically
are people that work at desks.
And other parts of the
government come to them
and say, well, we want to
know what's going on in Iran,
or we want to know what's
going on with Russia,
or we want to know about
Russian economic policies
or military policies.
And these people are these
really brilliant nerds
who come and become research
moles inside the CIA.
They're like graduate
students for life
who get to examine
and research stuff.
And then they write
up reports that
are forwarded to various
government officials.
And Bob's contract
was with a division
within this analytical side
of the CIA called the Illicit
Finance Group.
And the supposed role of
the Illicit Finance Group
was to follow money laundering
and illicit financial transfers
involving countries like
Iran or North Korea,
organized crime groups
or Russian criminals
or folks like that.
So there was a clear contract
that Ira and Dave showed me,
showing that Bob
worked for this group
and had been hired by this
group as an outside contractor.
And they believed that Bob had
been sent to Iran by this group
to try to recruit the
fugitive American there,
Dawud Salahuddin, as a source
inside Iran for the CIA.
Because bear in mind, in 2007,
the United States and Iran
are almost at war
with each other.
You've had president
Ahmadinejad who's
just become president of Iran.
He has restarted
Iran's nuclear program.
There is this raging
conflict going on in Iraq.
And Iran, according
to the US government,
is arming these
militants in Iraq
who are killing
American soldiers there.
The Bush administration
is about to clamp down
with sanctions against Iran.
So basically the
United States and Iran
are on a real collision course,
and there is a great desire
to have information about Iran.
So I'm going to stop for
a moment and read you--
So they're looking
for a reporter who's
going to try to find out
what's going on at the FBI,
at the CIA, give some aid
and comfort to the family,
try to find out what
happened to Bob.
And I say to them, look,
I'm happy to do that,
but I can't go just on the basis
of what you are saying to me.
I need to know more.
Are there are more
documents that you
have that talk to Bob's
involvement with the CIA?
And they said, well,
Bob's wife Christine
has all of Bob's
records, but she
hasn't shared them with us yet.
And I said, why not?
And he said, said, well you
know her husband's disappeared.
They have seven children.
She's in a state of panic.
I mean, they don't know
what's happened to this guy.
They don't know what to do.
And I said, look, I'm
willing to do what I can.
I'm willing to go to the ends of
the earth to follow the story,
but I need Christine to allow
me to see these documents.
So they speak with Christine.
A couple of weeks later, I fly
down to Dave McGee's office
in Pensacola, walk
into a conference room.
There, a reporter's
dream awaits me.
There are 10 crammed
cardboard boxes
filled with Bob
Levinson's files,
including all the reports
he's made to the CIA,
all the emails that he
sent between the CIA
and his handlers, lots of other
files involving other cases
that he's worked on.
And those files, those
e-mails, that information
become the basis that begins
this reporting trail that
starts in 2007
for me, will go on
for six years, six
or seven years,
and ultimately result in the
writing of "Missing Man."
So let me just read to you now
from the prologue of the book.
That will hopefully
set the scene for you
and set up some of the
characters for you.
Rain splattered
against the windshield
of her silver gray BMW as Sonya
Dobbs pulled up to a security
gateway blocking the street.
It wasn't much of
a gate, at least
by Florida standards,
just a long, rolling fence
stretching across a road.
She punched a code
into the gate's keypad.
After two unsuccessful tries,
she used her cell phone
to call her boss,
David McGee, who opened
the gate from inside his house.
It slid back and
Sonya drove through,
a laptop resting on
the passenger seat.
Sonya's Saturday night had
started very differently.
She had planned to spend it
sorting through photographs.
Sonya worked as Dave's
paralegal at a large law firm
called Beggs & Lane,
located in Pensacola,
a city at the western end
of Florida's panhandle,
the narrow, 200 mile
long coastal strip
tucked between
the Gulf of Mexico
and the states of
Alabama and Georgia.
Sonya wanted to carve
out a second career
as a photographer,
and she had been
on a chase boat the previous
day in Pensacola Bay,
snapping pictures of
a new ocean-going tug,
christened Freedom, as it
went through test maneuvers.
The photos showed the big,
black, and gray slicing
through the foamy water
under a blue sky filled
with white, puffy clouds.
Sonya had been happily
spending that Saturday evening
playing with different
ways to crop the images.
Then the telephone rang and
she heard a familiar voice
on the other end of the line.
Over the past three
years, she had
spoken to Ira Silverman hundreds
of times, if she had to guess.
Most days, the retired
television newspaperman
phoned her at least once.
Their conversation was always
about a mutual friend, Robert
Levinson, a former agent
with the Federal Bureau
of Investigation turned
private investigator.
Sonya had never met him,
though she felt as if she had.
Bob disappeared in 2007
while on a trip to Iran.
Dave and Ira, who had
both known him for years,
were trying to help his
desperate family find him.
Months after the
investigator went missing,
Dave convinced Bob's wife,
Christine, to ship his work
files to Beggs & Lane.
Sonya had read through them
and organized the reports.
She was a natural snoop,
at ease with computers.
Before long, she had tracked
down Bob's e-mail accounts
and figured out the passwords.
As she walked through
the records of his life,
she learned the secret that
Dave, Ira, and Chris already
knew.
The explanation that
US government officials
were giving out publicly
to explain Bob's reason
for visiting Iran
wasn't true, at least
not the part that
really mattered.
Since the investigator's
disappearance,
there had been reported
sightings of him
in Tehran's Evin Prison,
the notorious jail where
political dissidents
are tortured and killed.
Some tipsters had come forward
to claim that the Revolutionary
Guards, the elite
military force aligned
with Iran's Islamic
religious leaders,
were holding him at a
secret detention facility.
His family had made public
pleas for information about him,
and the FBI had assigned
agents to the search.
But the hunt for the missing
man had gone nowhere.
Ira's call was about an email
he had gotten earlier that
Saturday evening
containing a message that
read like a ransom note.
He had received
similar emails before
and had passed
them on to the FBI.
But this one wasn't
like the others.
This e-mail had a
file attached to it.
Ira told Sonya he
couldn't figure out
how to open the attachment
and was forwarding it to her
to see if she could.
The email read, "This
is a serious message.
Until this time,
we have prepared
a good situation for Bob
and he is in good health.
We announce for
the last ultimatum
that his life is based
on and related to you.
You should pay $3 million in
cash and release our friends.
We are waiting for
your positive answer
without any preconditions.
We would announce our way
to receive the money."
Sonya clicked on the
e-mail's attachment,
but nothing happened.
She didn't recognize the file's
extension, the three letter
code that tells the
computer which program
is needed to open a file.
She suspected the extension,
.flv signified it was a video
file, and she hunted around
on the internet for a player
to download.
She found one and
downloaded the software
and clicked again
on the attachment.
This time, the file launched
and a man's gaunt face appeared,
seemingly staring out at her.
He had closely shorn gray hair,
a mustache, and sunken cheeks
covered by stubble.
He started speaking in
a deep, raspy voice.
Strange music played
in the background,
rhythmic instruments accompanied
by a singer's droning call.
After a few seconds,
the camera pulled back
and Sonya could see
that the man was sitting
in front of a gray stone
wall in what appeared
to be a stark prison cell.
The polo shirt he
wore looked threadbare
and hung on his frame as though
it was several sizes too big
for him.
Part of the shirt's
right sleeve was gone.
There was nothing immediately
threatening about the video.
Masked jihadists weren't
standing over the man branding
guns or swords, and there
wasn't a black political banner
hanging behind him.
Still, the video
was disquieting.
The man's arms didn't
move as he spoke,
suggesting that his hands, which
couldn't be seen in the video,
might be lying
manacled in his lap.
He struggled to stay calm and
to keep his words measured.
Occasionally, his voice
came close to breaking,
and he would briefly close
his eyes, pause, or gesture
by turning his head.
He said, "For my beautiful,
my loving, my loving wife
Christine, and my children,
and my grandson, and also
for the United
States government,
I have been held here
for 3 and 1/2 years.
I am not in very good health.
I am running very quickly
out of diabetes medicine.
I have been treated
well, but I need
the help of the United
States government
to answer the requests of
the group that has held me
for 3 and 1/2 years.
And please help me get home.
33 years of service
to the United States
deserves something.
Please help me."
Dave McGee opened his front
door and ushered Sonya out
of the rain.
They went into the kitchen,
where the lawyer's wife
Joyce was waiting.
Sonya put her
laptop on the table,
opened it, and
launched the video.
Dave wasn't positive that
Bob was the man on the tape.
The last time he had seen
the former FBI agent,
he resembled a big, overweight
teddy bear with a mop of hair.
The man on the tape was so thin
that the skin on his throat
sagged.
Dave realized that the
only way to know for sure
was to call Christine.
Sonya dialed her number,
and when Chris answered,
she put her cell phone
next to the computer
and clicked on the video.
A few moments passed.
"That's Bob's
voice," Chris said.
"That's Bob."
So that's the
prologue for the book.
And it captures this
moment in time in 2010,
where after three
years of nothing,
three years of silence, three
years, where everyone involved
with Bob's case,
including the FBI, many
of his friends, many
people, including myself,
believed that Bob was dead.
It did not seem at
all possible that Bob
could have been kept somewhere
secret, out of sight, out
of view-- there were Americans
going in and out of prisons
in Iran-- that Bob could be
kept in some secret location
and kept alive for
this period of time.
I remember very clearly
where I was on that day.
Because my wife and
I were in Brooklyn.
We had been to our
daughter's school
for some parent teacher
conference or some event.
And I had said to
her, like when I
agreed to receive all this
information from the Levinson
family, I had told
them I would do nothing
to jeopardize Bob's safety.
That was the agreement, the
promise that I made to them.
And I had spent years
tracking down the route that
took Bob to Kish Island.
The people that the FBI
had recruited eventually
to help search for him,
and it was this wild cast
that I detail in the book of
arms dealers, and criminals,
and Russian oligarchs, and
all these kinds of people
who wanted something
from the US government
as part of the help
in the search for Bob.
And I had come to the
conclusion that day
that there was no way that Bob
Levinson could still be alive.
And I told my wife
that I'm going
to go into work on Monday.
I'm going to tell my editors
that it's probably time for us
to run our story.
And then I was at a restaurant
that evening with some friends.
And I got an email
from Ira Silverman
that had an attachment to it.
And I just excused myself.
I went out and I
looked at the email,
and I opened the attachment.
And what I saw was
that videotape.
And what I saw was evidence
at that point in time
that Bob Levinson was alive.
And as someone who had
followed this story,
someone who had spent
their life as a reporter,
it also blew my mind, because it
made me realize something that
was dawning on me through
the years that I was working
on this story was that I had
entered myself into the shadow
world, into this world of
secrecy, and criminality,
and surveillance, and
characters of moral ambiguity,
where you might presume
something was the case
and you could never be
sure it was the case.
And any assumption
you might make
would soon be
proven to be wrong.
There was another piece
of information showing
Bob was alive that came
out about four months
afterwards, in early 2011,
a series of photographs
that some of you may have seen
on the news, which showed Bob
this time with very bushy
hair and a big beard,
in this faux orange jumpsuit
like a Guantanamo prisoner
holding signs that were very
much of a political bent,
saying why haven't
you come to get me?
Why are you deserting me?
Isn't my service to
this country enough?
And the book follows this behind
the scenes search for Bob.
The video also set off
secret negotiations
between the United
States and Iran
to try to learn about
what happened to Bob.
the United States
came to believe
during the course of
those negotiations
that the Iranians were basically
playing the United States,
had basically taken Bob and were
using him in some ways as bait
to try to better understand
how the United States spies
on Iran.
Bob's fate was also a part
of these recent nuclear
negotiations.
And US officials
continued to press
their Iranian
counterparts about Bob.
And from the very beginning,
from the day Bob disappeared
in Iran to this very
day, Iranian officials
have claimed that
they know nothing
about what happened to Bob.
They know nothing about
how he disappeared on Kish.
And obviously anyone with any
working knowledge of Iran,
or at least a little
working knowledge of Iran
that I gained while
working on this book,
would find that
explanation absurd.
I mean, the Iranian government
and the Iranian intelligence
unit have some of the most
sophisticated surveillance
systems in the world.
They operate much like the
Stasi did in Eastern Europe.
They have neighbors
spying on neighbors,
taxicab drivers acting
as spies and reporting
about foreigners etc.
Who pick them up.
And the idea that
elements within Iran
be it the Iranian government
or the Iranian intelligence
authorities do not know what
happened to Bob Levinson
is beyond the pale.
One of the things that
also became clear to me
as I was working on
the book, and also one
of the more shocking and
depressing aspects of it,
is that in many ways our
government does not care
what happened to Bob Levinson.
Over the course of my
investigation, much of which
is detailed in the book,
there is clear evidence
of the Iranian involvement
in Bob's disappearance.
The FBI has been investigating
this case for eight or nine
years now and has
probably dossiers
that would fill this room
and go beyond it of the work
they've done to try
to gather evidence
about what happened to Bob.
And I believe if
the head of the FBI
was here today instead
of me, and one of you
asked him, do you believe that
elements of Iran's intelligence
hierarchy or religious hierarchy
were involved in the capture
and detention of
Bob Levinson, he
would have no alternative
but to say yes.
Because that is what most
FBI agents have told me
they believe.
But despite that belief,
the Obama administration
has done nothing to publicize
the involvement of Iran,
because sadly, they have a far
broader and different agenda,
which was the
Iranian nuclear deal.
And Bob Levinson,
his case, potentially
his life, his family's welfare,
became collateral damage
to the pursuit of that deal.
I mean, to the extent that
when these recent hostages were
released, or prisoners
were released,
they actually were hostages not
prisoners, since none of them
had committed any crimes,
by Iran in January,
the Levinson family
thought initially
thought that the United States
State Department and government
officials, White House
officials were actively
negotiating for Bob's
release while they
were negotiating for the
release of these prisoners.
And not only was the White
House not negotiating
on behalf of Bob
Levinson, the way
that the Levinson family, his
wife and Bob's seven children,
found out about this
release was the same way
every American did, when
they turned on the television
one morning and they
heard a news report
that four Americans have
been released by Iranians
in exchange for Iranian
prisoners held here
in the United States.
The Obama administration
didn't even
have the courtesy
to call the Levinson
family 15 minutes
ahead of time to let
them know that this husband and
this father wasn't coming home.
And now we know
that $400 million
was involved in the release
of these American hostages.
And one thing that I hope
in months and weeks to come
will be answered by
congressmen or someone
in authority is, why Bob
Levinson's fate was not
part of these negotiations.
We don't know whether Bob is
alive, whether Bob perished,
whether Bob was
killed, but what we
do know is that an American
citizen was captured,
detained, and possibly died at
the hands of forces within Iran
without any demands
for accountability
by this government.
And I guess,
ultimately, that's been
one of the most shocking
takeaways for me
from being involved
in this story.
Anyway, they put
a clock up there
to make sure I don't
run over too much time.
And I think I'm about 24
seconds beyond what I was
told how long I was told to go.
I could talk forever about
this, but if any of you
have any kinds of questions
about Bob's story, what we know
about him, what we
don't know about him,
the roles of the various
governments in this saga,
I'd be more than
happy to take them.
I guess there are
microphones there.
If you have questions to ask.
AUDIENCE: So I'm only about
40% done with the book,
so I don't know all the details.
BARRY MEIER: Did
I ruin it for you?
I hope I didn't.
AUDIENCE: No, no.
BARRY MEIER: OK.
AUDIENCE: It's a real page
turner so far, though.
I recommend you all pick it up.
So you said the US Government
hasn't been working
as hard as maybe they could or
should be about his release,
but even though everyone's gut
says Iran does this, if they
continue to deny at every turn
that they know where he is,
and there's no smoking gun,
there's no real proof that he
did it, how far can the US go?
And I guess as a
follow up, I was
wondering how the Iranian
government's public stance
on this compares to
other Americans who
have been arrested there.
I believe in 2009, there were
three hikers who were arrested.
How does their publicity?
Do they always have
this wall of denial?
BARRY MEIER: They're
both excellent questions.
And as to the first
one, since you're only
40% through the book, I
won't ruin the fact for you
that there are
some smoking guns.
And you'll get to one of them
towards the end of the book.
I have been told, along
with that smoking gun,
there's different
types of evidence.
There's evidence that you
would go to court with
to convict someone, right?
Beyond a shadow of a doubt.
Then there's evidence
that you could
put on the table
today that would point
to an inescapable conclusion,
that would be clear to anyone
looking at that evidence,
that the conclusion--
that there is no
other possibility,
no other reasonable possibility
that elements within Iran
were involved with Bob's
disappearance and capture.
And there is evidence of that
nature both within the book
and within the files of the FBI.
Because I have been specifically
told that by FBI agents.
FBI agents have said
to me the conclusions
you reach in the book,
which are essentially
the conclusions I've
just laid out to you,
we are so glad
that you did that,
because we are being
prevented from saying that.
And that's the
dilemma right now.
As to the other cases,
it's very interesting.
So there have been
over the years a number
of Iranian-Americans--
I know there
is a young Iranian-American
woman in the audience today,
so I will emphasize
this for her benefit.
Iran has made a habit of
arresting dual nationals,
because it does not recognize
the part of their nationality
that comes after
the Iranian part.
They consider
Iranian-Americans Iranians.
They consider Iranian-British
citizens Iranians.
But what's very interesting, and
I think very, very illustrative
in Bob's case, is
that all those people
were arrested and publicly
charged with spying,
like the hikers,
despite the fact
that there was no evidence
that any of them were spying.
Bob Levinson was in the broadest
definition of that word a spy.
He was there to spy.
He was there to gather
information for the United
States government.
He may have been there
on a rogue mission,
but he was there to spy.
And the Iranian government
pretended he didn't exist.
Because they saw a value to
him in being an actual spy
that they didn't
see in the people
that they put on these phony
show trials, spy show trials.
So I hope that
answers that question.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering, so they
would go out and announce
something about it?
BARRY MEIER: Yeah,
they would announce
like they arrest the hikers.
Hey, they're spies.
They keep them in the
regular prison system.
They march them out.
They pretend that there's some
kind of judicial proceeding
going on, that they're
following the laws of Iran
in indicting and
prosecuting a spy.
Bob never was in a prison.
He was kept in some
sort of black site,
like the CIA used to run.
He was never brought
into the judicial system.
He was never charged
in a court room.
None of those
proceedings took place.
Basically, they put
a bag over his head
and took him off to some
secret place somewhere.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
you weren't sure
if it was religious
or government
agents who were holding him.
Could you go into more depth
about the religious groups
there?
BARRY MEIER: Sure.
So basically we think
of the United States
and we think about
most Western countries
as having a government.
There's a single government,
and that government acts,
whether we agree with it or not,
in some sort of cohesive way.
So something happens.
It's the United States
government did it,
or the CIA did it, or some
formal government agency
did it.
Iran is a country that
is filled with factions.
So you have what we think
of as the government.
Then you have these
other factions over here,
like the Revolutionary Guards.
And they have their
own hierarchies.
And then you have
the religious groups.
And the religious hierarchy
with the Supreme Leader
at the head of it have
their own intelligence unit.
So you have these structures
that are not common to us,
but they are structures
that operate side
by side with each other.
Sometimes they operate in
silos from one another.
Sometimes they intersect
with one another.
And it's a very
confusing situation,
but it's very unlike
what we're used to.
Sir?
AUDIENCE: Does anyone
know or suspect
which group made the video?
BARRY MEIER: No.
I mean, what was very
interesting is that there were
great efforts made by whomever
was making the video to mask
who made it and to
mask any suggestion
that it was made by
any organized group,
be it in Iran or elsewhere.
For example, one of the things
that you will read about
in the book is what
the FBI did to try
to analyze the videotape.
So one of the things,
as I mentioned
in reading the prologue,
there is music playing
in the background.
And this music turns out to be
music from some tribal region
in Afghanistan.
Pashtun, it was a
Pashtun wedding song.
And the Pashtun people
are a large ethnic group
of people that are
in Afghanistan,
and Iran, and Iraq.
And basically the
purpose of that music,
according to FBI analysis,
was both to mask, cover up,
any ambient noise, that
when they're deconstructing
the tape, sometimes
they can hear people
on the street, planes overhead.
And that can be used as a clue
to try to identify the person's
location.
So it was both to mask
that ambient noise
and also to throw
out a false flag clue
as to where he might be held.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned negotiations.
Those negotiations were
made with an unknown party?
BARRY MEIER: I'm sorry, sir?
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned negotiations.
They were made with
an unknown party?
BARRY MEIER: No, they
were made with the Iranian
Ministry of Intelligence.
AUDIENCE: So that was
[INAUDIBLE] from the video?
BARRY MEIER: With the
government of Iran, who claimed,
we don't know
anything about him.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Thanks.
BARRY MEIER: Nothing.
Yeah, so those
negotiations went nowhere.
Sir?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm curious about your opinion.
Do you feel like he's
a real victim here?
Or do you feel like
it's a, "he made his bed
and he's lying in it" situation?
Or is it somewhere in between?
BARRY MEIER: I would say
it is somewhere in between.
Bob Levinson's a
fascinating character.
I mean, one of the
things that, to me,
and this goes back to like my
desire to be a fiction writer.
One of the hardest things
about being a fiction writer
is creating characters.
We like fiction when
we find characters
that we can relate to, that we
get into, that appeal to us.
And they don't have
to be always good.
They can be complicated.
I was given kind of Bob's
character on a plate
when I was given his
reports and his emails.
And his emails form the
dialogue in parts of this book.
You learn about
him as a character
through his reports
and his emails
and his interactions
with people.
And Bob, I guess as slightly
on the other side or middle--
I like to think to myself
psychologically that I'm still
a middle aged man.
And Bob, who was in his
late 50s at the time,
was fascinating to me.
Because we all come to a point
in our life, or many of us
do, where the world
is changing around us.
And we don't know whether what
we've done to make a living,
to be relevant, is
relevant anymore.
And people become
desperate, some people,
to find ways to keep
their hand in the game.
And that very much is where
Bob Levinson found himself when
he started working for the CIA.
He knew nothing about Iran.
He knew nothing about
the Middle East.
His expertise in the FBI was
with Russian organized crime.
But he had seven kids, so
he had financial pressures.
He was a person of
pride, who thought
he was a great investigator.
And so he was willing to
take a risk that I certainly
would have never
taken, most people
dreamed of taken.
But he decided to
take that risk.
So yes, in that sense,
he did make his own bed,
but it was a risk that,
to me, humanizing him.
AUDIENCE: It spoke
to you, that risk.
BARRY MEIER: Yeah,
it humanizes him.
It makes him much
more accessible
than some James Bond guy who's
like, oh well, I can do this.
I'm a high falutin spy.
It humanizes him.
It humanizes his story.
I mean, don't forget
that as a country,
as people, when
somebody goes out
and puts himself into danger,
they go climb a mountain
that they shouldn't be
climbing, they go out
in a boat into a rough sea,
they throw caution to the wind,
we don't abandon those people.
We don't abandon them.
We try to find them.
We try to rescue them.
We try to do what we can
to save them, particularly
in a case like this, where
whether you think what he did
was right or wrong, whatever
conclusion you come to,
you ultimately have to walk
away with the understanding
that he actually was
trying to do something
good for this country.
He may have been
wrong about that.
He may have been naive about
that and foolish about that,
but he did have the interests
of this country in mind
when he did what he did.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BARRY MEIER: You're
very welcome.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
a new administration
will be better for trying
to secure his release?
BARRY MEIER: To
me, the thing that
will bring Bob's
story to conclusion,
and I believe more
than anything and I
would like to see that
happen for his family,
having gotten to know his family
over the course of what is now
almost 9 and 1/2 years, I
want them to have closure.
They deserve closure.
They did not wish
this upon themselves.
They did not do anything to
bring this upon themselves.
And the people that took Bob and
held Bob and may have allowed
Bob to die are
visiting a cruelty
upon them that is
both unimaginable,
and unjustifiable, and baseless.
There's nothing to be
gained by it anymore.
Where our government
is concerned,
the best they can do, I
believe, by the Levinson family
is to lay out what they know
about the involvement in Iran
in his case, and then let the
chips fall where they may.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BARRY MEIER: You're
very welcome.
OK.
Well, anyway, it's one o'clock.
You guys get to go back to work.
I get to go back to work.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
I really, really
appreciate it, and I
hope that you enjoy
the book as well.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.